مباشر
لسه شويه
لسه شويه يا عمر
الفراش
السلام عليكم لا يمكن
معلش يا ابراهيم واحد انا مش شايفه
هتلاقيه مكتوب عليه
السلام عليكم
الصوت عالي قوي
السلام عليكم معلش اسف انا اخدت شويه وقت
عشان اتاكد بس لانه اخبار حضراتكم ايه يا
رب تكون يومكم سعيد وليلتكم سعيده ان شاء
الله انا كنت عاوز اقول حاجه قبل الاسئله
بس ما شاء الله جاءت الاسئله سريعه
كان نفسي في هذا الفيديو او في هذا
المباشر او في الفيديوهات المقبله
انه نعمل حاجه الناس كلها بتعملها وهو ان
احنا نركز على الموضوع اللي حضراتكم
وافقته عليه عاده ما بنعملش كده اتمنى انا
طبعا مش هتجاهل اي سؤال يجيني لو اعرف
الاجابه عليه بس اتمنى لو ناخد ده في
الاعتبار في المرات اللي جايه
السلام عليكم وعليكم السلام كيف حالك ربنا
يخليك فيصل مع حقيقه المفاوضات الامريكيه
مع سوريا في عمان
لا اعلم ان هناك مفاوضات امريكيه مع سوريا
في عمان ولكن الموقف المعلن في للولايات
المتحده هو
بعد اظهار التراخي من الاداره الامريكيه
او اعطاء ضوء اصفر على الاقل ان لم يكن
اخضر بان هم يذهبوا في اتجاه التطبيع مع
سوريا وحتى احد المسؤولين الامريكان قال
لهم بس خذوا مقابل كبير من التطبيع معه ما
يعني انهم لا يمانعون
في مجموعه من الاعضاء الكونجرس اظن 23
طرحوا مشروع قانون انه يعاقب الدول التي
تسعى للتطبيع مع سوريا كون ان في 23 عضو
مش معناها ان كل الكونجرس ومش معناها ان
ده بالضروره يكون اتجاه الاداره ولكن يعني
ونفس المشرعين دول طلبوا مره اخرى
يعني التشدد في تطبيق قانون قيصر الذي
يعاقب اي دوله
تسعى للتعامل الاقتصادي مع اداره بشار
الاسد
فبالتالي انا ما اعرفش انه في مفاوضات وان
كنت في عمان يعني ان كنت اعرف ان القنوات
يعني هناك قنوات اتصال لاسباب واضحه
وكثيره منها محاوله استرداد احد الصحفيين
او المواطنين الامريكان الموجود ده ده
السلطات السوريه الباشا ربنا يخليك يا
شريف استاذ سيد ده اخونا اكتب مره اسمك
انت صديق قديم نعرف اسمك لو انت حابب يعني
اليوم قرات خبر الاسبوع الماضي اليوم قرات
خبر الاسبوع الماضي بان الصين منزعجه لان
حلف النيتو فتح مكتب للنيتو في اليابان ما
جعلني اتساءل لماذا اليابان الان لم تنضم
الى النيتو هي فكره النيتو لما بدات بدات
اوروبيه يعني كانت فكره انه
الولايات المتحده
ومعها مجموعه من الدول طبعا في دول مش
اوروبا ما امريكا نفسها مش اوروبا كندا مش
اوروبا انما كان الفكره في حلف شمال
الاطلسي هو عمليه مواجهه الاتحاد السوفيتي
وبدات المساله دي في اوروبا
وحتى لما سعوا كانوا دايما التوسعه دائما
بتم الداخل اوروبا لمواجهه الاتحاد
السوفيتي وبعد سقوط الاتحاد السوفيتي ما
كانش فيه اي حاجه للتوسع فيه ثم يعني
وصلنا الى ما نحن اليه الدول التانيه
بتاخد وضع يقول لك انها دوله حليف من خارج
النيتو
زي اليابان زي بعض الدول اللي موجوده في
الشرق الاوسط مثلا زي قطر زي مصر زي
المغرب اظن فهما مش داخل النيتو ولكن يعني
هم على نفس يعني يعني
واخدين باتفاقات تخليهم ان هم يعاملوا
بشكل وثيق يتعاملوا ويقيموا مناورات وخطط
زي دول النيتون ده بصفه عامه بالنسبه
لليابان اليابان مش عاوزه
اليابان ما كانتش عاوزاه لان اليابان كان
ميثاقها او دستورها بعد الحرب العالميه
الثانيه انها دوله لا تشترك في اي احلاف
عسكريه فحتى لو النيتو كان قد توسع خارج
اوروبا
كوريا قصدي اليابان لم تكن لترحب بذلك
والا لكان كان الاولى بها انها تعسكر
نفسها وتصلح نفسها وهي قادره على ذلك
هل ده يتغير بقى كل شيء وارد وان كانت هي
مش محتاجه ان هي تكون جزء من حلف شمال
الاطلسي لانه العلاقات قويه جدا بحيث انه
اي شيء هيمثل يابان لابد ان حلف شمال
الاطلس يتدخل وما يمس حلف شمال الاطلسي
سوف يدفع اليابان للتدخل بقطع النظر عن
كونها عضوا ام لا
السلام عليكم السيد احبك في الله ده محمد
شباط ربنا يخليك ما راي حضرتك في الحل
العسكري العسكري لنووي ايران هل هو قريب
هو ليس فعالا في الاساس
وحكايه قريب انا ما اعرفش المستقبل في ايه
ولكن اعرف الماضي كان فيه ايه والماضي
بيقول لنا انه القصه دي مطروحه من 2003 من
بعد ما عرف العالم انه في غفله منه ايران
كان عندها برنامج
النووي متقدم
مدام نووي متقدم والناس لا تعلم عنه شيء
فلازم يكون هناك علامات استفهام عليه ما
انت لو عاوز تولد كهرباء لو عاوز تعمل بحث
علمي هتعمله سري ليه ومع ذلك من 2003 حتى
الان لم
وكانت في مبادرات كتيره من اسرائيل
واحيانا من الولايات المتحده لضرب ايران
وكلها فشلت بسبب سبب للتبسيط يعني ان
عواقب ضرب البرنامج هيكون كبيره جدا على
المنطقه على الدول اللي هتضرب
تجربه العراق قد قاسيه على الولايات
المتحده اسرائيل ما تقدرش تعمل ده لوحدها
ثم بقى الحاجه اللي احنا اتكلمنا عنها
كتير واستاذنكم ترجعوا لحواراتنا مع
الدكتور يسري ابو شادي هي فكره انه لو
تتذكروا ماذا فعلت اسرائيل في
النموذجين السابقين النموذج العراقي ضربت
العراق اظن في سنه 81 وهي منشغله تماما
بحربها في العراق اللي بدات من 80 ل 88
وضرب مفاعل على السطح في مكان واضح
ده التجربه الاولانيه التجربه التانيه في
2007 المنشاه التي قالت اسرائيل انها كانت
مشروعه نوويا سوريا وانكرت سوريا ذلك في
2007 ايضا كان مكانا محددا
فسيليتي كامله كده تم ضربها ما ان ضرب
المفاعل اللي ضرب في العراق او المفاعل
الذي ضرب في سوريا تقريبا تم تصفيه هذا
المفاعل وتقريبا يعني تم تصفيه الطموح
النووي بالنسبه لسوريا اذا كان كان اذا
كان موجودا يعني الانسولين بينكروا وفي
العراق اجهد البرنامج لفتره من الزمن وبعد
كده حاولوا يطوروه مره اخرى لكن ظل
الامريكان والاسرائيليين لهم بالمرصاد
والبرنامج في بدايته ايران الوضع مختلف
لما العالم عرف ان في برنامج في ايران
كانت ايران قد تعلمت الدرس اولا نجحت
بدايه في تكوين قاعده ضخمه جدا من العلماء
والفنيين والقدره على تصنيع مكونات
البرنامج فاصبحت المعرفه موجوده في مئات
العلماء والفنيين الايرانيين فان ضربت
عالم ظهر عالم وان ضربت علماء ظهر علماء
اثنين تضرب الفاسده او المنشاه اللي هنا
هتجد لها بديل واتنين وتلاته وعلشان تدمر
كله معناها ان انت تدخل في حرب تستمر
لشهور وسنوات طويله والخسائر هتكون مهوله
ورد الفعل الايراني هيكون ضخم وتاثيره على
كل دول المنطقه كبيره جدا هذا ما اعلم
وبالتالي استبعد
ان هم يقوموا بعمليه زي ما قاموا بها في
سوريا والعراق ولكن لا استبعد ان تستمر
محاولات التخريب والاثاره
ومحاوله تقويد ايران من الداخل
استاذ سيد لماذا لان الياباني عمله احتياط
مع انهم متذبذب بشكل كبير عبد الرحمن
السويفي التذبذب يا صديقي لما بيكون في
حدود العشره في الميه
هي مثلا بيكون شيء مقبول من وقت لاخر لكن
اللي مش مقبول خصوصا في العملات اللي فيها
اللي هي متروكه للعرض والطلب تماما
انما اللي مش متروك لغايه طبعا وما يكونش
كل يوم يعني مش كل يوم بفقد 15 على فترات
بسبب ازمات يقوى ينخفض انما
التذبذب الحقيقي بقى يبدا 20
و30% زي بعض العملات وفي العملات طبعا
اكتر بكتير وبشكل غير مستقر فده هو اللي
يثير الخوف انما لما بتكون عمله مستقره في
العموم والتذبذب بتاعها محسوب 5% 7%
قد يصل الى عشره 15 في بعض الاحوال لكن مش
دايما فده مقبول يعني
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله حسين جواد السلام
عليكم محمد مساء الخير ما تاثير انتهاء
معاهده لوزان على مستقبل تركيا والله يا
موسى انا ما اسمع المعاهده لوزان دي الا
بصراحه في صفحات السوشيال ميديا انا اسفه
انا ما اقصدش يعني انه يعني اقلل من
يعني من الناس اللي هي بتطرحها ولكن هي
ايه معاهده الاوزان الدوله التركيه
الحديثه لما نشات
نشات
على انقاذ الامبراطوريه العثمانيه
الامبراطوريه العثمانيه خسرت الحرب
العالميه الاولى وكان قبل الحرب العالميه
الاولى كتير من مستعمراتها بدا يستقل عنها
زي بلغاريا وزي صربيا وزي غيرها يعني
ما تبقى لها من مستعمرات زي منطقتها زي
دولا اللي كانت بتسيطر عليها في دول الشرق
الاوسط بعد
هزيمتها في الحرب العالميه الاولى اراد
المنتصر في الحرب العالميه الاولى ان
يكررها من هذه المستعمرات وبدا يفرض عليها
مجموعه من الاتفاقات
لوزان وصفر وغيرها
استطاع كانت مكحفه جدا طبعا استطاع كمال
اتاتورك والقاده اللي معه انهم يدخلوا في
حروب اخرى عشان يقللوا الخسائر عشان كده
بيعتبروه بطل قومي في تركيا لفترات طويله
انما في النهايه قوته سمحت له بانه بيحتفظ
بتركيا الموجوده الحاليه وما قدرش انه
يسترد اكتر من كده حافظ فقط على هذه
التركيه التي تعرفها الان اتفاقيه لوزان
اتفاقيه مؤسسه للحدود التركيه اللي انت
شايفها الان موجوده عليها تركيا اللي انت
بتزورها او بتشوفها
الاتفاقات في القانون الدولي النظريا
اعتقد انا مش متخصص في القانون الدولي
بتبقى لي فترات يعني هي عقدت في 23 تنتهي
قد تنتهي يعني انا مش متاكد في 23 انما
انتهت لم تنتهي الاتفاقات اللي هي بتاسس
البنود اللي بتتعلق
بالبنود ملهاش فتره زمنيه والا لو كل
اتفاقيه
شملت ايتمز مختلفه
بقت بتنتهي صلاحيتها معناها ان انتهاء
اتفاقيه لوزان لو كان هناك بند ينهيها بعد
100 عام يعني بما فيه بند الحدود معناه ان
احنا في هذا العام انه لم تعد هناك حدود
لتركيا وعلى تركيا ان تبحث على حدود جديده
لها هذا كلام عبثي وبيتم استغلاله بقى باي
طريقه انه المشكله انه كان لانه كان في
فتره اردوغان داخل فيه خصومات مع كثير من
اعدائه وكتير لو هنا من اصدقائه ومن يسبب
الارض غنيين بالاردوغانيين العرب انه كل
تقصير كان بيتم كان يقولوا هو ما ان تنتهي
هذه الاتفاقيه حتى سوف حتى تحقق اردوغان
نهضتها وعظمتها هو الراجل حقق كتير من غير
من في وجود هذه الاتفاقيه واذا هو يعني
يوفق يعني وعالج المساليب اللي موجوده
تستطيع ان يحقق المزيد بهذه الاتفاقيه ومن
غيرها فلا اعتقد انه
الاتفاقيه لها كل هذه الاهميه كما يصور
البعض يعني
وبالمناسبه لا توجد بنود سريه لانه السؤال
ان هناك اتفاقيه لوزان لها بنود
سريه في السؤال هي عقدت
ومضى عليها اطراف والاطراف دول اكيد مش
اتنين ولا تلاته ومره مئه سنه في كل
الارشيفات اين هي البنود السريه واذا كانت
اخفيت على مدار مئه عام فكيف يعلم بها وكل
الناس اللي بيكتبوا عليها في السوشيال
ميديا
استاذ سيد يعطيك العافيه على تواضعك
مش لحظه ده سرفا ومجهودك ممكن شرح لو
باختصار لماذا خريطه اذربيجان لديها جزء
بعد ارمينيا منعزل عن اضرب ايجن السبب ما
هو اخونا ده جزء من الماساه بين ارمينيا
واضرب ايجان
لو فتحت خريطه ارمينيا
هتجد انه في جزء
في
اذربيجان يخص ارمينيا وفي جزء في ارمينيا
يخص اذربيجان الاغلبيه الاثريه او يعني
جزء اذربيجان بتقول ان هو يتبعني ولكنه
يقع في ارمينيا ده جزء من السياسات التي
اتبعها الاتحاد السوفيتي في محاوله
السيطره على الشعوب بانه
زي مثلا هنا في مجموعه كبيره من الارمل
يضع جيبا للدوله الاخرى اللي هي التابعه
للاتحاد السوفيتي يبقى تابع للاذريين او
الاذربيجانيين والعكس فتظل دايما في حاله
من توازن الموجود وما فيش دوله قادره او
مستعده ان هي تستقل بنفسها او منسجمه بشكل
واحد يتم تهجير الاداريين الى ارمينيا
والارمنيين الى اذربيجان وهكذا
وطبعا ده كان يعني سياسه ضمن سياسات
مختلفه اتبعها الاتحاد السوفيتي وخصوصا
تحت حكم ستالين يعني في اداره شؤون البلاد
للسيطره على هذه المستعمرات الكثيره اثرها
ما زالت باقيه الى الان وتعذب
الاذربيجانيين والارمان او الاذريين او
الارمن
على فكره انا بحاول افتكر دلوقتي في
الجزيره
في جزيره ما بين عمان والامارات برضو
مشابهه كده بس انا
ذهبت عن ذهن الان
شريف اشرف بحبك جدا الله يحفظك ويخليك هل
سنموت كلنا هنموت طبعا ههه عبد الكريم ما
حدش هيعيش العمر كله مش كده عمرو ولا ايه
طيب
السلام عليكم ايمن عليكم السلام السلام
عليكم لدي سؤال هل تستطيع البنوك
في
دولي في دوله ما ان تذهب باموالها لدوله
ثانيه عبد الرحمن لا مش فاهم السؤال يعني
هي تستولي على الاموال وتسرقها هيبقى
عمليه يعني سطر او سرقه من رئيس بنك او
كذا انما مش فاهم سؤالك يعني ايه انا رئيس
بنك ومعايا الريال السعودي وعندي مثلا
500 مليون ولا تريليون ريال سعودي اسرقهم
واروح بهم فين اروح بهم الامارات مثلا
اروح بيهم السودان اروح بيهم امريكا
مش فاهم السؤال
اذا خد هو جزء من الاموال يبقى سرقه لكن
هياخد كل المدخرات هيحولها ازاي وفين ما
هو عمليه التحويل بتبقى معروفه يعني انت
يعني انا هحول من كذا الى كذا حولها على
ايه هيعمل حساب لنفسه البنك هيعمل حساب
تاني فاي اموال
بتذهب من بنك الى بنك لازم جهه الارسال
واضحه جهه الاستقبال واضحه الهدف من
التحويل واضح وفي اطار معين وبالتالي فكره
ان رئيس بنكي قرر انه يحول كل ادارات والى
جهه اخرى مش عارف هي فين طبعا مساله غير
وارده يعني اذا كنت فهمت سؤالك السيد ما
هي تعديعات مقتل الجنود الثلاثه
الاسرائيليين ياسر
والله انا يعني الواقع دي طبعا احنا عندنا
اكثر من روايه روايه الحكومه المصريه اللي
هي الروايه الرسميه بتقول ان الجندي قتل
الجنود الثلاثه قبل ان يعني يتم استشهاده
او قبل ان استشهد وفقا للروايه الرسميه
المصريه وهو بيطارد بعض اللي هم تجار
المخدرات او الجريمه المنظمه يعني
ظهرت روايه بتقول لا والله ده صفحات بعض
الصفحات اللي بيقولوا عليها داعش وما داعش
بتقول ده والله احد جنودنا يعني
بدا الناس الدوله المصريه قالت شككت تاني
اتقالت انه اللي بيقول ان ده داعش عاوز
يحرجنا ويقول انه احنا مش مسيطرين على
الحدود على كل الاحوال الروايات كثيره
اسرائيل بادرت بانه كل واحد كان حريص على
ان يؤكد انه امر هيتم التحقيق فيه ولكن لن
يؤثر على العلاقات والروايه الاسرائيليه
والموقف المصري فيما هذا هو الموقف السليم
سليم في ايه مش في تفسير الحادث الحادث
مخدوع للخاضع للتحقيقات ودي الروايه
المصريه وهم بيحققوا في المساله
ولكن المؤكد المؤكد انه
ايا كانت التفاصيل اللي هتنتج عن
التحقيقات
ومساله ضبط هذه الحوادث في المستقبل
الدولتين حريصتين جدا جدا جدا على استمرار
التعاون لان ما فيش دوله فيهم مستعده
للدخول في مواجهه او الى تصعيد الخلافات
فيما بينهم اسرائيل مستعده ان تتجاوز عن
الجنود الثلاثه واضعافهم على الا تعكر
صفوها مع جبهه بحجم مصر
والعكس والعكس سليم ايضا
استاذنا وافتكروا ما حدث في حوادث سابقه
يعني بين البلدين
حسين جواد الله عليكم السلام
قلنا هذا الله يحفظك
عمر بيقول كيف سيتاثر دخول الاقتصاد
الاوروبي في ركود على الاسواق الناشئين
احنا عندنا كتله الاقتصاديه تلاته يا عمر
الاتحاد الاوروبي وعندنا الصين وعندنا
الولايات المتحده اللي هي القتل الاكبر في
العالم وبعد كده عندنا اقتصادات مهمه يعني
اقتصاد الهند اقتصاد البرازيلي اقتصاد
احنا شفنا لما اوكرانيا حصلت فيها مشكله
ايه اللي حصل يعني لكن دي الاقتصادات
الكبيره جدا ركود معناه ايه معناها تراجع
النشاط الاقتصادي يعني
الانتاج بيقل والانتاج بيقل ليه لانه عنده
مشكله الاسعار مثلا مصادر الطاقه غليت جدا
انه عنده حرب ايا كان الاسباب ادى لركود
فمعنى كده ان النشاط الاقتصادي يتراجع لما
الاقتصاد النشاط يتراجع معناها انه كان
بينتج شاي مثلا بما يعادل ساي مثلا 16
تريليون دولار الاتحاد الاوروبي مجتمع في
السنه بقى ينتج ب 16 ماينس واحد او اتنين
في الميه ما بيزيدش ده معناها انه اولا
داخل الاتحاد الاوروبي هيكون فيه تراجع في
الوظائف هيكون في تراجع في مستوى المعيشه
يكون في تراجع في مستوى الصادرات هيكون في
تراجع في مستوى الواردات تاثيره علينا ايه
زي ما انت بتسال بقى اذا كانت اتحاد
الاوروبي مثلا مثلا بيستورد مواد خام من
دوله ما هيحتاج اقل اذا كان بيحتاج انه
يستقبل عماله ماهره من دوله ما هيكون
حاجته اقل وعليه فلازم يكون التاثير
بطبيعه الحال سلبي على الدول اللي هي
بتصدر الى الدهاد الدوله اللي هي اصابها
الركود وطبعا كل ما كانت الكتله
الاقتصاديه كبيره كل مكان تاثير التراجع
الاقتصادي فيها اكبر على العالم
السلام عليكم لدي سؤال هل تستطيع الان
مساء الخير يا استاذ الله يحفظك لا كده
الاسئله نطت مني جامد
ارجع تاني احاول افتكر احنا التاثير
انا هرجع تاني بس هي الاسئله ظهرت ده محمد
صفوت بيقول تاثير انهيار السد الاوكراني
على زراعه القمح واسعار الحبوب بشكل عام
والاثاره هتبقى ضخمه جدا يا محمد انا طبعا
مش عارف يعني تاثيره على القمح على وجه
التحديد او الحبوب بس انت عندك انسانيه
انت عندك السد اللي هو كخوف كاظن اللي كان
وراك كميات كبيره من المياه وكان موجود في
منطقه خرسون وكان يعني سيطر كان حريص احد
اهداف العمليه العسكريه الروسيه والحرب
الروسيه تسيطر على منطقه تحديدا علشان
تسيطر على السد ده اللي بيغذي شبه جزيره
القرن لما انهار هذا السند وكل دوله بتقول
انه الطرف الاخر هو اللي ورا ضربه
كميات مهوله من المياه هتغرق كميات مساحات
كبيره من الاراضي هتهلك المساحات المزروعه
هناك تهلك بيوتها كلها تاثير كبير لكن ردا
بقى على تاثيره على زراعه القمح تحديدا او
الحبوب الاساسيه مساله محتاجه دراسه هو قد
ايه من الاماكن اللي غمرت بالمياه هي قمح
وحبوب اساسيه لا اعلم من المبكر مش من
المبكر يعني لا اعلم من المبكر ان احنا
نعرف حجم المياه والضرر هيوصل لقد ايه في
المناطق اللي يعني لسه بتتدفق من السد وان
كان انا قبل ما ادخل التسجيل قالوا ان هي
تباطئ تباطات قليلا يعني
لكن هي كارثه لا شك وتقول لنا ان الحرب
لسه داخله على مقاس كتيره لان في عمليه
تصعيد مستمر في هذه الحرب
السلام عليكم
شكرا لك نعتذر على الاسئله الخارجه عن
المواضيع اريد ان اعرف مصير مفاوضات انبوب
الغاز النيجيري المغربي
لم اتابعه من اربع او خمسه شهور ولكن من
اربع خمسه شهور كان هذا المشروع اللي هو
هيبقى مشروع يبدا من من نيجيريا ويتجه من
خلال عده دول وصولا الى المغرب الى
الاتحاد الاوروبي كانت مشكلته بس اولا
يعني في التكلفه الكبيره جدا وانه يحتاج
اظن اربعه او خمس سنوات لما تابعته حتى
يتم انجازه لكن لا اعلم اذا كان تباطا في
الفتره الاخيره ام لا يعني يحتاج ان انا
اراجعه يعني
مرحبا تحدث عن الشهيد محمد لا اعلم عنه
شيئا يا ابو سليمان
ومش عارف اللي بيعرفوا بيجيبوا المعلومه
لماذا تخفض السعوديه انتاجها من النفط لكن
على الطرف الاخر روسيا تزيد انتاجها لماذا
تفعل المملكه ذلك يا محمد بالنسبه للجزء
الاولاني من السؤال السعوديه بتخفض
انتاجها من النفط بحثا عن مصالحها اذا كان
في الطلب قليل نتيجه وجوده ركود او خلينا
نقول نتيجه تراجع عن الطلب بغض النظر عن
كلمه ركود
فانخفض اسعار البترول من مستوى
الميه وعشرين والميه في بعض الاحوال بعد
من مارس وابريل
2022 الى ان استقر عند معدل التسعين 95 ان
الاسبوعين اللي فاتوا كنا بنتكلم على
مستوى السبعين فده مستوى لا يحقق الربحيه
المنشوده لكثير من الدول المنتجه ما
بيخسرهاش بس ما بتربحش كثيرا يعني فاذا
استمر على نفس معدلات الانتاج هيحافظ على
نفس الانتاج مستويات الاسعار المتدينيه
وربما تهبط اكثر فلما يقلل الانتاج
هيبقى
هيتعطش الى
البترول يعني وبالتالي يبتدي نتيجه قله
المعروض يزيد السعر ده بالنسبه للسعوديه
انت بقى بتقول ليه روسيا بتعمل كده روسيا
كانت دائما من على الاقل من 2020 بتنسق
تماما مع من قبل 2020 باستثناء وقع يعني
واحده منذ ان اصبحوا
بلس يعني بدايه اظن من 2016 اذا ما خدتش
الذاكره هم بينسقوا مع بعض تماما باستثناء
وقعه واحده في 2020
وسرعان متجاوز الخلافتهم بين نساؤوا مع
بعض في الوقت الحالي روسيا اصلا مضغوط
عليها بسبب المقاطعه فالمفروض نظريا ودي
المعلومات اللي هي موجوده ان هي اصبحت
تنتج اقل بكثير من حصتها
نتيجه انه هي طبعا ده نظريا على الورق
لانه في دول كثيره مقاطعه منتجاتها ولا
ترغب في شراء بترول يعني لكن في اقاويل
كثيره بقى ان هي مستمره في الانتاج وان هي
بتعطيه لدول اخرى والدول الاخرى بتعيد
تصديره
يعني على انه منتجات هنديه منتجات اي دوله
اخرى يعني هذا لا يمكن حسابه بدقه
يعني خلاصه الاجابه الجزء الاولاني واضح
انه ما فيش تعارض مزعج للولايات المتحده
ولا في علامه استفهام انه السعوديه ان
روسيا بتقول انتم تقللوا وانا سوف ازيد ده
ما بيحصلش المفروض ان الاتنين بينسقوا مع
بعض بشكل مقبول
يا سيد كيف اطور من نفسي
سياسيا احمد ما تطور نفسك سياسيا يعني
تعرف سياسه ام تطور نفسك سياسيا يكون لك
مهنه كسياسي اذا كنت عاوز كسياسي انا لا
اعلم
ما اعرفش على حسب بلدك اذا كانت فيها
احزاب انضم لاحد الاحزاب وكذا اذا كنت في
دوله لا يوجد فيها احزاب عليك ان تعرف فين
النخب الحاكمه وتحاول ان انت تتقرب اليها
وربنا يوفقك معاش عارف انما اذا كنت عاوز
تقول ازاي اعرف سياسه
معناها انه انت تبتدي تهتم بالشان العام
الاولاد الشان العام لبلدك ثم تبتدي تهتم
بالشان الدولي اذا كنت مهتم بالشان الدولي
وفهم الشؤون الدوليه موضوع بياخد وقت
لانه معرفه السياسه مش هيجي من الجرايد
ولكن انا بشوف بحاول اخد فكره عن يعني انت
عاوز تفهم بلدي ان زي مثلا ان انت عاوز
تعرف
المكسيك مثلا وانت عمرك ما تعرف ايه
المكسيك دي اول خطوه لازم افتح اطلس اشوف
موقعها على الخريطه فبلاقي موقعها اهم
حاجه الخريطه ومن الخريطه ومن المعلومات
الجغرافيه اذا عرفت ان المكسيك دي مثلا
موجوده هي كده كذلك بس انا بدي لو انا
معرفش خالص ان هي موجوده في جوار دوله
عملاقه زي الولايات المتحده لازم تعرف
كويس جدا ان هي لابد ان تكون خاطئه لهذا
العملاق الكبير وان اللي بيحدد اولويات
السياسه الخارجيه لهذه الدوله هي الدوله
العملاق اللي هي موجود فيها زي الدول اللي
موجوده بجوار روسيا زي الدول الموجوده
بجوار الصين وهكذا اذا علمت ان الدوله ديت
مستويات دخلها منخفض لازم تعرف ان بينها
مشاكل والدوله الكبيره مشاكل هجره لان
الفقراء هيذهبوا الى الدول الغنيه اذا
وجدت ان هي دوله بتروليه وهكذا يعني فانت
بتعرف من الخريطه ومن التفاصيل اللي
موجوده حاجات اساسيه اذا كانت دوله حبيسه
يبقى لازم هكون شخصيتها مختلفه عن الدوله
اللي محاطه بكثير من الشواطئ الدوله
الحديثه هتبقى اما عدوانيه عاوزه ان هي
تحارب الدول الاخرى حتى تجد منفذ الى
المياه او دوله مستانسه بالطبطب على الكل
علشان الجميع يساعدها في الخروج عندنا
امثله وامثله جميله وبالمناسبه احنا كنا
تتطرقنا اليها في نعرف في حاجه حلقه اظن
باسم سر المكان او حاجه ازاي الموقع
الجغرافي بيح شخصيه الدوله زي الجينات
الوراثيه ما بتحدد شخصيه الانسان
ديكم مثل واحد حتى لا اطيل عليكم اذا نظرت
للخريطه تقدر تفهم سويسرا تماما من
الخريطه انظر الى سويسرا افتح بعد الهواء
يعني سويسرا تلاقي دوله حبيسه وهي محاطه
بمجموعه دول في مجملهم وهم اقوى من سويسرا
على الاقل تاريخيه
لانها دوله حبيسه ومحاطه بدول قويه كان
تاريخيا ان هي مضطره ان هي تجد لنفسها
وسيله للتعايش مع هذه الدول بعلاقات طيبه
حتى تستطيع ان تنفذ او يسمحوا لها بنفاذ
سلعها الى العالم الخارجي طيب السلع ديت
عشان تنفذ الى العالم الخارجي تختار ايه
بما ان هي ما عندهاش بحار وهي راغبه في ان
هي يعني تصدر كتير اختارت سلع زي ما
بيقولوا كده ما خف مش اختاره يعني مش
قعدوا مع بعض دي الحاجه بتيجي كده تلقائي
اكيد لو انا صدرت س لعه دبابات وسيارات
عمليه صعبه لكن لو صدرت ساعات مثلا
ومجوهرات لو عملت خدمات مصرفيا ده يخلي
حاجه الناس الي اكتر وهيخلي قدرتي على
التصدير عن طريق الطيران اللي هو اكثر
تكلفه اقل ان انا اصدر ساعات اكتر بصدر
عربيات
يخليني افهم ليه سياسه الحياد انا محتاجه
كل هؤلاء فلابد ان اكون محايد يفهمنا
يخلينا نفهم ليه ان الامن لازم يكون قوي
جدا جدا جدا في بلد زي سويسرا لان هي
عاوزت مش عاوزه تكون ساحه للجواسيس
وعمليات الاجرام بين الدول ديت اللي
احيانا بتتحارب واحيانا يعني
بتمارس اساليب خشنه فيما بينها عاوزه تضبط
الامور وهكذا فمعرفتك ليه الجغرافيا حاجه
اساسيه معرفتك لاساسيات الاقتصاد حاجه
اساسيه معرفتك للتاريخ في اي دوله بتحاول
تعرف فكره عن جغرافيتها فكره عن تاريخها
فكره عن وضعها الاقتصادي ثم عن تركيبتها
السكانيه اللي هي جزء من الجغرافيا فيها
مكونه من اعراض كثيره مكونه من مذاهب
كتيره دين واحد ولا اديان كتيره وبالتالي
تقدر تعرف مدى الانسجام بين هذا المجتمع
وهكذا يعني
كل دي معلومات انت بتعرفها
بالتدريج واذا اردت ان انت تعمل دي يعني
تطور هذه الملكه او هذه القدره هي عمليه
ممتعه بتاخذ وقت لكن المهم ان انت ما
تعتمدش على نشرات الاخبار او الجرايد او
الماده الخفيفه او التقشوس انت كل يوم ما
اعرفش طبعا المرحله الثانيه اللي حضرتك
فيها ولكن اذا زي ما احنا بنتفرج على انا
بقول لبعض اصدقائي او الشباب يعني طب اقرا
ساعتين في اليوم فل كتير يعني طب ما
الفيلم الواحد ساعتين مسلسل الواحد ساعه
الا ربع يعني فما فيش مانع ان انا استثمر
ساعه او ساعتين في قراءه ما اعتقد انه
مفيد لنفسي يعني
مش ابنك رامي عمرو بيحب التاريخ
هو لو عاوز بقى هو ده الحل يقرا كل يوم
ماذا يحدث لليره التركيه الليره التركيه
المساله باختصار انه
المستثمرين او المضاربين الامين بعد نجاح
اردوغان من انه يعاود الى نفسه اسلوبه في
اداره السياسه النقديه
طبعا انا خايف اكون بكرر نفس لان احنا
قلنا الكلام ده في اكثر من حلقه ولكن انت
حضرتك سالت
هو اللي بيضارب على الليره التركيه عاوز
يبقى يمشي ان البلد تمشي على نفس
الاساليب اللي هي مستقر عليها في السياسه
النقديه يعني لما يكون عندي تضخم يبقى
لازم ازود سعر الفائده لما يكون عندي ركود
انا بخفض سعر الفائده بزود سعر الفائده في
برفع سعر الفائده لما بيكون عند الاسعار
مرتفع عشان اسحب السيوله اللي في ايدين
الناس فيقل الطلب فبدل ما الناس بتشتري
قلمين هيشتروا قلم واحد بدل ما بيشتروا
اكل كتير هيشتروا اكل قليل على قدهم وهكذا
فيقل الطلب فتهدى الاسعار لما بيكون عندي
ركود زي اللي انت اشرت اليه او احد الزمل
احد الاصدقاء اشار اليه عند ركود ما فيش
نشاط اقتصادي انا بخفض الفائده علشان اشجع
الناس على الانفاق مش الادخار فلما ينفقوا
يبقى وتبقى اسعار القرود قليله يقترضوا
اكتر والمستثمر يقترض فا المصنع او
المستثمر ايا كان مجاله يعمل والمستهلك
يشتري سياره وبيت وملابس وكذا فيبقى في
نشاط اقتصادي دي السياسه اللي معروفه لكن
ما يفعله اردوغان هو حاجه استثنائيه
مدرسه موجوده في السياسه النقديه يمكن
قالها اقتصادي واحد
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
طبعا حد على طول يقول طب ما هو قدر يخفض
التضخم من التمارين الى
خمسين او اربعين ايوه بس لازم نبحث عن
الاسباب تم تخفيض التضخم ازاي ما انا لو
قتحت مثلا مثلا كثير من السلع الاساسيه
مدعومه من الدوله زي الغاز اللي اتعمل
هيقل الانفاق لكن هيقل الاحتياطي هيقل
هيقل التضخم لانه الناس بتنفق اقل على
الغاز اللي اصبح مجانا في البيوت لكن ده
على حساب ايه على حساب الاحتياطي اللي
بيتم استنزافه من البنك المركزي
وهيكون عاجز بعد كده عن انه يدافع عن
الليره انه يعمل مشروعات وبالتالي يضطر
يقترض ولما يقترض يزيد التضخم وهكذا
فده اللي حصل له دائره توقعات من
المستثمرين انه اردوغان يعود الى نفس
السياسه بقول اردوغان ليه لانه كانت هذه
القناعاته وكل محافظ بنك مركزي عارضه
اقاله
تاثير انهيار السد اجبناه استاذ سيد جبيل
شكرا لجهودك ربنا يخليك يا محمد
السيد سؤالي عن نفوذ المخابرات البريطانيه
في حرب روسيا ودورها في اشتعال الازمات
والتبع تبعيتها للسي اي ايه والى اي درجه
ستتحمل روسيا الهجوم عليها من جانب الجميع
في اوروبا واي دوله ممكن ان تنال من غضب
الروس والله يا ربيع الجزء الاولاني من
سؤالك
الملفت للنظر منذ بدايه الصراع انه
بريطانيا
بتتحول الى عامل زي المرصد السوري او مرصد
حقوق الانسان اللي هو
دايما يسالوه في كل انا يعني انا حبيت
اعرف يعني طبيعته مقدرتش اوصل لاجابه في
اصدقاء مشتركين بيننا وبين القائمين على
المرصد السوري بس انا عشان ما يفهمش انه
في اساءه لكن انا دايما عندي علامات
استفهام وهم بيعرفوا كل المعلومات دي فورا
اول ما تحصل عمليه في سوريا فيطلع
المسؤولين عن المرصد ولا قتل فلان وفلان
والعمليه تمت من الناحيه دي وعدد القتلى
يعني حاجه غريبه لكن اوكي
المخابرات البريطانيه عندها تفاصيل كل شيء
واضح وصريح ويعني
وطبعا كانت لعبه دور اكبر بكثير يعني
الحقيقه من مشاركه بريطانيا في هذه الحرب
دايما السياسه الخارجيه البريطانيه والدور
البريطاني الحقيقه يبدو دايما على السطح
اكبر من قدرات بريطانيا ودي قصه يكون
شرحها بحكم تاريخها
وحرصها دايما ان هي تكون في الصوره وانها
دوله عندها فيتو في مجلس الامن لكن
واحد السبب الرئيسي في القصه ديت انه يعني
اسباب تاريخيه اسباب داخليه
واسباب تتعلق بظروف بريطانيا بعد خروجه من
الاتحاد الاوروبي الاسباب التاريخيه هي
كانت من الدول الاساسيه اللي اشرفت في
مطلع التسعينات على استقلال اوكرانيا
واشرفت على الاتفاقيه اللي بموجبها استقلت
اوكرانيا عن
اتحاد السوفيتي
ووافقت روسيا على هذا الاستقلال في مقابل
ان هو طبعا ان هي تسترد او ان هي تحصل على
كل الاسلحه النوويه وده كان من مصلحه
الغرب اكتر من روسيا للاسلحه النوويه كلها
تكدس تحت دوله واحده وما بيبقاش في انتشار
نبوي اتنين
سبب داخلي انه الازمه اندلعت بينما كانها
برجونسون
ثم ومن خلفوه ويعانوا من ازمه اقتصاديه
كبيره جدا ناتجه عن مجموعه من الاسباب
اهمها خروجهم من الاتحاد الاوروبي
وحرمانهم من اهم شركاء تجاريه ليهم فبالغ
جدا جدا في اشغال الناس بالازمه الخارجيه
السبب الثالث ان بريطانيا بعد خروجه من
الاتحاد الاوروبي حريصا ان هي تقول
لامريكا خريطه حريصا تقول الاوروبيين ولا
دول العالم المختلفه اننا قادره على ان
العب دورا مهما جدا على المستوى الامني
وفي اي ازمه في اوروبا وغيرها وبالتالي لا
تستبعدوني انا خرجت من الاتحاد الاوروبي
لكنكم ما زلتم في حاجه اليها انا خرجت من
الاتحاد الاوروبي لكني قادر ان اقدم
الكثير لدول الشرق الاوسط لافريقيا لاسيا
وهكذا يعني
وطبعا يعني هي من الدول مش غريبه في كرهها
لروسيا يعني ولكن الاسباب دي بتزود جرعه
نبرتها العاليه اللي لفتت نظر الفرنسيين
وسموها الامست يعني انت مزعجه بزياده
وعماله تشعل الحرائق
كلمه ممكن تضايقهم يعني هم بينسقهم يعني
دي عمليه التابعه دي كلمه مش مناسبه يعني
لكن
انت بتقول جزء من السؤال بقى اي دوله
ستنال من غضب الروس ما هي الروس مشتركه مع
كل الدول الغربيه والدول الغربيه ما تاثرت
كثيرا
بتبعات الحرب لكن قصدك حاجه عسكريا اذا
حدث عسكريا هتبقى طبعا ماساه كبيره لانه
معناها ان هي اشتبكت بشكل مباشر لا مواربه
فيما حلف شمال الاطلسي لكن كل الدول تاثرت
الروس تاثروا بشده الاوروبيين تاثروا بشده
الامريكان الاثر هيكون بعيد المدى لان
واحد من اثار هذه الحرب انه الناس فقدت
الثقه في الدولار بعد العقوبات والاستحواذ
على الاصول الروسيه وبداوا يبحثوا عن عمله
اخرى غير الدولار
وبداوا يدوروا ظهرهم للامريكان حتى دول
الشرق الاوسط لا يثقوا فيه كلام الامريكان
يعني
انا هتحرك ببطء كده علشان الاسئله لما
تجريش مني يا عمرو
هل لو حصل تغيير سياسي في مصر ممكن الخليج
يدينا فلوس وما اعرفش عمرو والله ما اعرفش
يا اسلام
مش عارف
محمد صفوت تاثير انهيار السد الاوكراني
اجبنا هل الديون هل الدين يمكن ان ينفع
الدول عند الحكم من خلاله
انا قلت رايي قبل كده انا ما اعرفش ان اصل
انت
يعني حد يحكم من خلال الدين دي انا ما
اعرفش تجربه واحده نجحت
لا في التاريخ على الاقل الحديث يعني في
المئات السنين اللي فاتت اصله يحكم من
خلال الدين معناها انت عندك نص وفي قائمين
في الدوله هيسعو للترجمه النصوص ما هو
الدين بيقول ايه يعني انا عاوز مثلا
كل يوم في مستجدات النهارده في نص موجود
من 1400 سنه او او قبلها اذا كان في
المسيحيه واليهوديه النصوص موجوده هيجي
الدوله اللي هتحكم باسم الاسلام او
اليهوديه
او اي حاجه قدامه نصوص وفي مستجدات بتيجي
كل يوم عاوزين نعرف راي الدين في ده الدين
لا يتكلم انما يتكلم به الرجال فهيجي بقى
الناس القائمين ويبتدي يفسر النص ده
التفسير دايما دايما بيكون وفقا لاحواء
هؤلاء
او قناعتهم بلاش اهوائهم وعليه ممكن تجد
المساله ماشيه وفقا لاهوائهم يعني
عاوز ادي لحضرتك مثال ممكن ادي لك عشره
عشرين تلاتين اربعين خمسين ستين في كل
دوله يعني
بلاك العربيه السعوديه في السنوات القليله
الماضيه كان كثير من راي رجال الدين في
اتجاه جاء الامير محمد بن سلمان عنده رغبه
في التجديد وهكذا علماء كتيره غيروا من
ارائهم فقط فجاه وفوجئت ان احدهم يعني من
كم سنه قال ان انا كنت مخطئ وانا ليه قلت
كل الكلام ده قبل كده في مصر
موقف من اسرائيل مثلا اختلف على حسب
الفتره الزمنيه في فتره من الفترات لازم
يعني نحارب الاسرائيليين ونحارب اليهود
وفي فتره ثانيه وان جنحوا للسلم فاجنح لها
ويجيبوا ايات السلام وهكذا
انا راجعت الفتوى دي تحديدا وانا كنت يعني
مشغول بحاجه معينه ان الفتوى تغيرت بتوجه
القياده
طب بتقول لي طب ما هو في رجال دين عندهم
يعني صلابه وكذا ايوه بس ده واحد اتنين
تلاته اربعه خمسه سته ويمكن الاطاحه بيه
تماما يعني وياتي بغيره على زي ما احيانا
في الدوله تستطيع ان انت تتخلص من قاضي ما
اذا ما كانش يعني دوله مستقره فيها
الاعراف تتصاعد تتخل تتخلص من رجل الدين
وتسكته تماما
فضلا عن ان بقى العدد الكبير يعني في عدد
كبير من رجال الدين
على كل الاحوال انا ما اعرفش حد يقول لي
تجربه ناجحه مثلا تجربه ايران تجربه حكومه
الانقاذ في السودان
التجربه السعوديه
التجربه ايه يعني مش عارف ايه التجارب
يعني حاول تفتكره معايا كده وقولوا يعني
مساء الخير انا علي
ده سامسونج الله يخليك يا علي
استاذنا هناك زياده في تسهيل الصينيين
لسنداتهم في امريكا وشراء كميه اكبر من
الذهب هل تعتقد ان الصين جاده في انشاء
بديل الدولار سريعا في المدى المنظور على
وجه اليقين يا اخونا الصين جاده في هذه
المساله على المدى المنظور هي اللي محلشك
وذكر حضرتك انه اظن في 2016
اظن في 2016 كانت اول مره صندوق النقد
الدولي كان عنده اربع عملات اساسيه
بيسموهم عملات الاحتياط
او اللي هو بيعتمد عليهم فيما يسمى بوحدات
السحب الخاصه
خايف اشرح وحدات السحب الخاصه دي فتاخذ
الحلقه يعني ولكن صندوق النقد الدولي لما
بيدي لك قرض بيكون مقوم بما يسمى بوحدات
السحب الخاصه اللي هي بتمثل قيمتها بسكت
من العملات الاربعه الاساسيه اللي هو
الدولار والجن والسترليني والحاجات دي
واليور طبعا اضف لهم لاول مره اليوان
فاصبح عملات السحب الخاصه او عشان بلاش
بكلمه عملات السحب الخاصه اصبح العملات
الرئيسه اللي بيعترف بها الصندوق كعملات
مهمه داخل الين لاول مره وده كان انجاز
كبير لدوله كانت تعتبر دوله ناشئه لغايه
فتره صغيره لغايه اوائل التسعينات يعني
ثم التطور الكبير جدا اللي حدث مع انشاء
منظمه البريكس والبنك الاسيوي للاستثمار
ثم الان دول كثيره بدات تستقبل
العمله المحليه في تعاملاتها باعتبار ان
القبول بعمله اليوان
بيوافي جزء من الشروط ما انت عشان تكون
عمله احتياط لها شروط
من ضمن الشروط ديت هو حجم التجاره الدوليه
للدوله صاحبه التجاره انا بصدر كتير وهي
بتستورد كتير عملاتها طبيعي انها يكون في
يعني احتياج لعملتها لكن في شروط اخرى مش
بس حجم التجاره ولكن ان العمله دي مثلا
تكون مش مثلا يعني من بين عوامل اخرى ان
هي تكون
تحركاتها محل ثقه من العالم كله ان هي
تكون عمله حره مش منابيوليتد او انت متحكم
فيها كما يفعل الصينيين ففي شروط تسعى
الصين الاستيفائها تكون في طريقه اكثر
سلاسه في تسويتها تسويه المعاملات اللي هو
الساتل من
[موسيقى]
الانتقال بقى يعني تكون عندها نظام زي
النظام السويفت بديل هم بيسالوا كل السبل
ديت بحيث ان اليوان
جايز مش على المدى المنظور ولكن في
المستقبل يكون قادر ان لم يكن قادر على
مناطحه الدولار فعلى الاقل تكون الصين
قادره على الهروب من السطوه الامريكيه
اللي ممكن ببساطه تخليها تجمد الاصول
الصينيه
كيفك رمدو انا في احسن حال والحمد لله
احمد سؤالي لك استاذ سيد برايك كمال
المستفيد من تفكير سد خرسان
مش عارف والله يا احمد
هو السد واقع في المناطق اللي هي بتسيطر
عليها روسيا او بتحتل لها روسيا
ما اقدرش اقول لك غير وجهتين النظر لكن
فعلا هيكون من القفز على الحقائق اننا
ندعي لانه
يعني انا ما اعرفش طبعا هم حتى بعض
المسؤولين الغربيين في كل الاحوال هو
هيدين الروس هيدين فعلها الاوكران لن
يقولوا شيء لان المساله وصلت الى مستوى فج
من النفاق انت دين الممارسات الروسيه
ويقول عليها اجراميه قول كل اللي انت
عاوزه هذا واضح دوله اعتدت على دوله رغم
انه في يعني عندها مبررات ولكن اوكي ده
مفهوم لكن ان انت
بتتردد في مثلا
اصدار احكام على امور واضحه السلاح الغربي
الذي اعطيته للاوكران
يتم ضرب الروس به وتقول والله انا لا
اشجعها هو انت يعني لا تشجعها وانت مش
قادر على منعها هي اوكرانيا لن تصمت اياما
يعني بدون الدعم الغربي على كل الاحوال
وجهه نظر بتقول انه الروس فعلوا ذلك علشان
يعطلوا التقدم الاوكراني انا مش قادر احكم
على الكلام ده على خلفيتي المعلومات
القليله جدا اللي بستقيها من عسكريين
ولم اسال فيها كثيرا يعني في دردشه يعني
انه هو ده كان هيمنع انهي هجوم يعني احنا
ما عندناش معلومات عن الهجوم المضاد وكان
هيجي منين وكان هيجي من النهر مثلا ما
كانش في ما سمعت ان ده ما كانش احتمال
كبير انما يجوز دي وجهه نظر ان هم يعيقوا
هذا التقدم لا توجد علامات على ان هذا
التقدم كاسح وكبير ويحتاج الى تفكير سنت
لكن وارد
والامر الثاني اللي هو بدالي في البدايه
انه اكثر منطقيه ان ضرب السد هيؤدي الى
حرمان شبه جزيره القرب على وجه اليقين من
امدادات المياه وشبه جزيره القرب وروسيه
بتقول هذه ارضي وامر مستقر فيسبب متاعب
للروس
ولكن من المبكر ان انا اقول من فعلها
وممكن يكون الاتنين مفعولهاش بالمناسبه
انت عندك السد تعرض الى عمليات ضرب قديمه
المياه ارتفعت قد يكون بعامل الاهمال من
الروس قد تكون ضربات اوكرانيه قد تكون
ضربات الروسيه قد تكون جماعه مخربه لم
تحسب الامور ففي امور كتيره محتاجه وقت
للتحقيق وفي امور مش هتظهر ابدا
اذكركم مثلا بمن فجر نورد ستريم وانا
يعني رغم انه الدلائل قالوا في الاول بدون
مواربه فعلها الروس ثم كل التحقيقات بتقول
لا لم يفعلها الروس مره يقولوا فعلها
الامريكان ومره يقولها فعلها كومندس
اوكراني ده كده في غيبه تماما من اهم
شركائهم يعني الغربيين
من فضلك استاذ
ماندو لعدم تكرار الاسئله اعمل سلو داون
احنا النهارده معنا عمرو عمرو حجاج
فاصلك الطلب يا عمرو عاوزك يعني تعمل ان
انت تقلب بصراحه حاسس ان هو مساله ماشيه
كويس يعني مش محتاجه انا اللي عجوز فبتوه
في الاسئله معلش
ماذا سيحدث لاخونا احمد صلاح ماذا سيحدث
للعقوبات الموجهه لروسيا في حال تمكن
الرئيس الامريكي القادم من وقف الحرب يعني
تتراجع العقوبات يعني تبقى يعني خطوه خطوه
التزاما مقابل التزام والله احنا رئيس
قادم انت بتفترض يعني وهيبتدي يعمل
مفاوضات اكيد لا يمكن الروس هيوافقوا على
اتمام هذه المفاوضات
والا اذا كان في تعهد برفع العقوبات
حسين الشمري مساء الخير هل بشار الاسد كسب
الصراع وانتهاء الصراع ولا في اعمال ان
يتم الوصول سياسيا لحل وسط على الاقل
بمعنى هل من الممكن ان تكون
الكتب اصدق من السيف
انا مش عارف يعني اصدقائي من السيف دي
قصدك بها ايه بس هو كلام انا مش فاهم ولكن
انا فاهم الجزء الاولاني من الصراع الجزء
الاولاني من السؤال يا حسين قال الصراع في
سوريا انتهى لا
الصراع مكتوم في سوريا
ومشيتم تحرك كبير في سوريا الا اذا
حسمت قضايا كثيره الصراحه
وان في طرف خرج اقوى نسبيا من الاطراف
الاخرى انما هو خرج قادر على قمع الاطراف
الاخرى عسكريا او الناس كلهم خلاص يعني
مثلا
البشار الاسد يعني بسط سيطرته على المساحه
الاكبر ما زالت هناك مشاكل في الجنوب
مازال القرد مستقرين مع حلفائهم في الشمال
الشرقي ما زال التركي محتلين عشره في
الميه من سوريا الوضع ده صعب انه يستمر
الى الابد يعني
فعلشان تقول انه يحسم صعب يستمر للابد
لانه في دفع اقتصادي الناس في ادنى
المستويات الاقتصاديه فصعب ان يستمر الحال
وتستقر الامور ما لم تكن هناك حل لمشاكل
للناس اقتصاديه الاول قبل مشاكلهم
السياسيه وعليه
فلازم قضايا كثيره تحسم علشان
المساعدات تيجي عشان عمليه الاعمار وده لن
يتحقق الا بالتفاوض والتفاهم بين الدول
الكبيره الروس والامريكان والايرانيين
والاطراك ودول المنطقه يعني
انما لو تقصد انه السيف يعني
هل برايك سوف تغزو الصين تايوان ام لا وما
هي التداعيات التي سوف تحدث في حلقه من
الصين على هذه الخطوه احمد زكي ده ده سؤال
القرن ده اذا حدى ذلك فسوف يكون تطورا
خطيرا جدا جدا جدا
وتقدر بقى تتكتب عليها كتب واطوال الوقت
هذا السؤال هو المطروح في دوائر صنع
القرار في اليابان في امريكا في الصين في
تايوان نفسها في كل دول اذا اقبلت الصين
على تايوان واحد كيف ستكون المواجهه يعني
معنى ذلك ان انه فشلت كل الجهود السلميه
في الاقناع الصين بعدم غزوها وفشلت كل
الجهود في اقناع تايوان بالانضمام الى
الصين معنى ذلك في مواجهه عسكريه هتبقى
عندنا بقى سيناريوهات
هل الصين تستطيع ان هي تنهي المساله ديت
بحزم بحسم يعني في فتره صغيره ولا هنكتشف
ان احنا امام اوكرانيا مضروبه في عده
اضعاف
اذا وجدنا ان هي حرب طويله هنبقى بتتكلم
على ماساه جديده هتاثر على العالم كله كله
واذا كانت حرب قصيره لصالح مين طبعا صعب
ان احنا نتخيل هذه الصين ممكن نتخيل
احراجها بس في الحاله ديت لو نقول الحرب
قصيره وانتهت يبقى لازم تكون بانتصار
الصين اذا انتصرت الصين يعني قامت بدمه
تايوان معناها انه حصل خلل يعني يصعب جدا
ان تتخيل انه قابل للاصلاح في القرن ال 21
لان الصين هتكون استحودت على هذه الجزيره
الغنيه بكل امكانياتها تكنولوجيه واحد
اتنين هتتحكم في مضيق تايوان فكل ما يذهب
الى مثلا اليابان
يعني في اتجاه اليابان تستطيع ان هي
كوريا تستطيع ان هي تسيطر عليه الصين
هتبقى ماسكه البر الصيني وطايوان بص على
الخريطه عشان تتخيل انا بقول لحضرتك ايه
وكل ما ياتي من مضيق تايوان من الشمال الى
الجنوب يعني هتسيطر على بحر الصين الجنوبه
كله بكل ثرواته فلاني وتترك طبعا
الامريكان ما انا سي طرت على هنا وعلى هنا
ما الذي سوف يبقى الامريكان هناك فانت
بتتكلم على حدث
يعني حرث قادر على تغيير قواعد اللعبه
وموازين القوى بين الامريكان والصينيين
متى تتجرا روسيا والصين على انشاء حلف
مقابل نيتهم وهم انشاوا يا صديقي يعني ده
الياس يعني انشؤوا حلف بمعنى ايه تقصد حلف
عسكريه لا هم بينهم يعني مش هما ما فيش
بينهم حلف عسكري مكتوب يعني وان كان بينهم
مصلحه مشتركه انه يكونوا في شراكه رغم
يعني طبعا تصوراتهم المختلفه للحياه انه
من مصلحتهم الان ان ينسقوا فيما بينهم
لمواجهه عدو مشترك اسمه الولايات المتحده
وحلفائها
بس مش لازم تبقى مكتوبه يعني بالمناسبه
حتى في حلف شمال الاطلسي انه لو حصل
اعتداء
على دوله مش ان هي تعتدي اذا حصل اعتداء
على دوله لو اعتدت ده حاجه ما تخصش الدول
الف شمال الاطلس لو كان حصل اعتداء عليها
مش اوتوماتيك ليه الحزب لازم الحلف لازم
يعني يعني
يتصدى للدفاع عنها ده لازم يرجع
لبرلماناته كل دوله ترجع لبرلمانها وممكن
البرلمان يقول لا يعني يعني
تفعيل الماده الخمسه مش اوتوماتيك اللي مش
قضاء وقدر يعني ممكن تيجي فرنسا تقول تروح
لبرلمان لا مش هنحارب يعني احنا مش طرف في
هذا الموضوع مثلا يعني
اللي بيحرك الدول مش الاتفاقات اللي بيحرك
الدول المصالح اكثر من الاتفاقات هي ممكن
دائما تلاقي سبب ان هي تتنصل من اتفاقاتها
يعني
مرحبا استاذ سيد لماذا تنهار ايران
اقتصاديا لماذا لم تنهار ايران اقتصاديا
وتعلن افلاسها رغم حصارها وعقوباتهم ضخمه
عليها سفيان لانه على مدار الاربعين سنه
الماضيه
قدروا انه
يتعاملوا مع هذا الحصار
او ان هذا الحصار حفز فيهم كل ما يمكن ان
يحفز في شعب يعتقد انه محاصر من العالم
كله وكان تاثير الحرب العراقيه الايرانيه
ضخم جدا على الايرانيين لانه كانت قناعتهم
يعني انا بتكلم على وجهه النظر الايرانيه
وليست وجهه نظري ان هم ظلموا واننا تم
الاعتداء علي من صدام حسين اللي كانوا
شايفينه رمز واداه للشر وانه العالم كله
او جيرانهم كلهم انضموا اليهم وهن وان هم
اخذوا على غره في لحظه ضعف وكانت خسائرهم
ماهوله جدا
والصواريخ
العراقيه
اخذها من الاتحاد السوفيتي
ودول العربيه اخرى يعني الحقد اذى كثيرا
بالمدن ثم استخدام الكيماوي او امتلاكه
للكيماوي كل ده خلاهم
يقرروا الاتي انه لن يفيدك احد الا قدراتك
الذاتيه فكان الاعتماد على القدرات
الذاتيه واحده من استراتيجيات الثوره بدا
هو يبقى يصنع صواريخه بدا الفكره علشان هو
عانى من الصواريخ العراقيه فلم يعني يهدا
حتى طور قدرات صاروخيه واصبح واحد من عدد
محدود جدا من دول العالم عدد محدود جدا
على اصابع يعني اليدين تقريبا اللي هو
عنده يعني صناعات محليه صناعه وطنيه
للسواريخ دول العالم ما بتسمحش للدوله ان
هي تطور صراحه الدول الكبيره مش بتفرض
بسبب معاهدات ولكن بتمارس ضغط ان تظل
صناعه الصواريخ
خاصه بالدول الكبيره فقط فهو عمل ده كان
حريص انه يطور اسلحه او القدره على امتلاك
اسلحه دمار شامل هو بيقول اكيد هو عنده
كيماوي اكيد عنده بيولوجي ولكن المؤكد انه
اصبح على العتبه النوويه ايضا يعني بسبب
التجربه اللي حدثت له اثناء الحرب النوويه
وهكذا الحرب العراقيه الايرانيه فهو كان
عازم وعنده شعور بخطر شديد وبالمناسبه ده
هو اللي خلى برضو اليهود او الاسرائيليين
يطوروا لانه كان هم عندهم خوف يعني مزروع
في قلوبهم انه هيتم ابادتهم هو ده اللي
خلل باكستانيين يطوروا سلاح نووي كان
عندهم اعتقاد انه طالما الهنود امتلكوا
لا امل لنا في الحياه ولا مستقبل لنا الا
اذا طورنا لانه هذه عدوتنا واصبحت تمتلك
سلاح نووي فسوف نبذل الغالي والرخيص حتى
لو اكلنا اعشاب ولا حشائش الارض زي ما قال
احد زعمائهم لابد ان نطور سلاح نووي وهو
ده السبب اللي دفع كوريا الشماليه ان تفعل
نفس الشيء وقبلهم الصين لم تهدا حتى طورت
سلاح النوويا خوفا من ان يتم العدوان
عليها من الدوله الشقيقه الكبرى الاتحاد
السوفيتي او من الامريكي
الياس سالت سؤال كتير يا الياس
يوسف استاذ سيد ممكن سؤال شخصي كم عمرك 54
في اكتوبر القادم ان شاء الله
وفقتك ديرك من هو مفجر السد في اوكرانيا
لا اعلم انا اجبت على السؤال يا صديقي هل
ممكن تشرفنا
برؤيه ماندو
ماندو هيكون معنا الاسبوع الجاي انا معي
دلوقتي صديقي عمرو اللي هو يعني المايسترو
البرنامج من تاسيسه الاساسي يعني
بس احنا عشان دايما كان منضده هو اللي
بيشاركني فيه البث المباشر لكن اللي بيصور
البرنامج على طول عمرو
ان شاء الله المره الجايه يجي هنا ويتكلم
معكم
علي ابو
هو مندو مش عنده هو قناه خاصه بها على
عنده قناه هو مسميها
بتاعه
ايوه صديقي انا
[ضحك]
انا بسوق لكل اصدقائي يعني هو بس هي قنوات
وبتعمل يعني هو بيعلم الناس او بيتكلم
الناس على السوشيال ميديا وازاي تستفيد
وازاي تعمل صفحه فيسبوك وازاي كذا يعني
اللي مهتم بهذا ممكن يستفيد من تجارب مندو
في هذا
متى تتجرا روسيا والصين على انشاء حلف
مقابل اجابنا
كيف يمكن للخارج هندسه ان يحصل على دراسه
في مجال السياسه والاقتصاد احمد الصميلي
معرفش دولتك ايه بس دول كثيره الجامعات
بتشترط فيها انه علشان تيجي تدرس اقتصاد
لازم تكون خلفيتك اللي هو اللي هو يعني
التخصص اللي انت فيه ينفع تبني عليه يعني
ممكن تيجي من كليه تجاره فتدرس اقتصاد بس
صعب تيجي من كليه طب واعتقد صعب من هندسه
انما انت مش محتاج تدرس في كليه يعني يعني
في الدراسه في الكليه كويس انما اصبح
العالم مفتوح الكلام ده كان يمكن زمان
شويه في اقتصاديين كثير بالمناسبه انت انت
بتقول لي هندسه في اقتصاديين كثيره
خلفيتهم هندسه فقط وابتدى يدرس
بقى ازاي على حسب ظروف بلده اذا كانت
الجامعات بتسمح له ان هو يدرس ويكمل من
غير ما يكون
الليسانس او البكالوريوس بتاعه متوافق
وفقا
لوائح كل جامعه وكل دوله يعني
انما لو ده مسموح يبقى جميل لو مش مسموح
فدراسه
الاقتصاحه بعيدا عن مقاعد الجامعه في
اماكن كثيره جدا وتستطيع ان تدرس اقتصاد
وتدرسها بعمق لو انت حابب
ويتوقف على خلفيتك لو خلفيتك زيرو
تستطيع ان تذهب الى مواقع كثيره بتشرح
الامور بالتدريج ولا تحبط اذا انت بتحصل
كل مره عشره في الميه عشرين في الميه
لانها عمليه تراكميه لكن اذا كنت عاوز
تدرس لازم تعمل الاتي حدد هدفك الاول هدفي
ايه ان انا اشتغل بالاقتصاد فانت محتاج
تسال حد الاول انت عاوز اعمل كذا عشان
الهدف كذا الهدف الفلاني فممكن يبدد لك
هذا الهدف من البدايه ويقول لك ان ده مش
هينفع حدد هدفك الاول
اذا كان عمل وتغيير كارير هيبقى انت محتاج
تسال عن الهدف اللي انت عاوزه كيف يمكن
ونعد الدراسات اللي انت تحتاجها لان
الاقتصاد زي الطب في تخصصات كتيره جدا
عشان ما تضيعش وقتك والاساسيات طبعا مطروح
لكله اذا كنت عشان تفهم اقتصاد فهذا لا
يتطلب هذا السؤال ولكن يتطلب منك انك
تبتدي تقرا فيه الاسياد تسمع فيديو
انا مش
مش قصدي يعني انه اقول على نعرف اقتصاد
ولو قلت يبقى مش عيب يعني انا بتكلم على
القناه اللي انت مشكورا بتتابعها احنا
بنحاول نعمل ده وعلى فكره ده بتكلفه كبيره
تكلفه كبيره يعني ايه يعني احنا ضحينا
بفكره اللي هي المشاهدات وهكذا احنا بناخد
على تعليميه يعني مع صديقي الاقتصاد
المحترم الكبير اللي انا بتعلم مستفيد منه
هاني هنا يعني
وبنبذل جهد كتير في تبسيط المسائل
عشان نعمل الهدف ده طب بنضحي بايه كان
ممكن نختار موضوعات تانيه كده يعني وبسيطه
وكده ما فيهاش هذا الجهد ولا الارقام ولا
العناوين اللي تبدو والضل
كان يبقى اسهل كثير لكن هو الهدف برضو ان
احنا نوفر
منصه ممكن تعلم ناس اساليب
باي سكس في الاقتصاد لكن بعيدا عن هذه
القناه اللي ممكن تضيفها على القائمه هناك
قنوات اخرى خاصه لو كنت تعرف لغه انجليزيه
ده احمد اسماعيل ابراهيم الهلالي استاذ
سيد احبك ربنا يخليك ويسعدك والله شكرا
جدا ابراهيم هل التصالح
التصالح العرب مع ايران تصالح حقيقي
وسيدوم انه مؤقت
تصالح العرب مع ايران هو تصالح نتيجه
اخفاق الوسائل الخشن او اجهاد كل الاطراف
ايران مش قادره
هو العرب مش قادرين
هل يدوم او مؤقت بمجرد ما يتغير موازين
القوه ما فيش حاجه تدوم ابدا لا شيء يدوم
ابدا وبالتالي دوامه الحال من المحال
المساله كلها
متوقفه على توازن القوه يعني تخيل كده
مثلا انه انه ايران حصل فيها تغيير وحصلت
فيها فوضى وكذا تفتكر هيكونوا يعني حريصين
قوي على انقاذها يعني وكده ولا يتمنوا لو
يجهزوا عليها والعكس
لكن اتمنى ان يدوم
لا لشيء الا انه انت عندك حقائق لن تزول
هيفضل الشعب الايراني موجود هيفضل الشعوب
العربيه موجوده
قامت حروب قام الثورات هي موجوده يبقى
التعايش حتى رغم الخلافات نحاول نتفاهم
عليها بدل ما ندير هذه الخلافات
طوال الوقت بتدمير كل منا للاخر يعني اللي
انا بقوله ده طبعا انتم عارفين وجهه نظري
في المساله قلتها كتير كتير
ومش عاوز اقول بفضل الله ان انا كنت صح
وان انا قلت
ونرجع ل 2018 وقبل 2018 ما احبش اقول
الكلمه دي بس عاوز اقول للناس اللي كانوا
بيسخروا من اللي انا بقوله طب ما هو حصل
يعني مش حاجه غريبه يعني وقد يفشل اوكي
دوله تتعثر ما في دول عندها شروط البحرين
حتى شروط المصري بتتفاوض بقى لها شروط
بتقول والله انا عندي شروط بس على الاقل
مش انا اعمل ميليشيا واضرب بها ايران
وايران تعمل ميليشيات وتضربني ونستنفذ
شعوب ونقتل شباب شوفوا حجم الخسائر اللي
موجود في اليمن هتقدروه بكام ده كل الشباب
اللي بيموت واللي اتدمر ده في موقف غريب
جدا احد مراسل القنوات
خد ورقه وكتب عليها انا احب سوريا
واعطاه لمجموعه من الاطفال اللي موجودين
في المعسكرات اطفال سوريين اطفال ما شاء
الله يعني في سن تسعه وعشره يعني مش
صغيرين وحتى الورق قدامهم لا احد يقرا طب
تكلفته ده قد ايه يعني تكلفه عشر سنين هو
لا يقرا يعني عشان يتم القراءه اذا عادت
الحياه محتاج يكون سنه كام يعني
الحياه علشان يبتدي بقى انت تخلصه من كل
اثارنا يتعلم ويبقى مهندس قادر على
المشاركه ولا طبيب ولا محاسب ولا بنكير
ما هي الفرق بين حماس والجهاد ومنظمه
التحرير اي فروق انت بتتكلم الفرق الاساسي
ان منظمه التحرير ارادت اله ان انا مستعده
القبول اول من مبادره بالقبول باسرائيل
وقال انا مستعد خلاص ان احنا نقبل
باسرائيل وبحدودها اللي تنص عليها الامم
المتحده على اساس انه اسرائيل تعمل معنا
اتفاق وترجع الى حدود ما قبل خمسه يونيو
يعني اربعه يونيو 1967
ونعمل مؤسسات وعملنا اسلوب الى اخره حماس
رفضت هذا والجهاد رفض ذلك ثم اصبحت الحماء
حماس مستعده رغم رفضها نظريه لاسرائيل على
التفاوض معها عمليا لانه هي في قنوات
مفتوحه وفي وسطات وتمام على ان تستقر
الامور لها في غزه
الجهاد
اكثر تشددا من حماس في ذلك لانها ليست في
موقع المسؤوليه وطبعا هي حضورها اقل فلو
انت عاوز تقول الفرق الرئيسي ان منظمه
التحرير تعترفوا علنا بحق اسرائيل في
الوجود
حماس نظري عمليا تعترف بحق اسرائيل في
الوجود لكنها لا تصرح به عمليا الجهاد
نظريه لا تعترف بحق اسرائيل في الوجود لكن
مستعده طبعا ان تقرب بفروق
بحقائق موازين القوى المختله لصالح
اسرائيل
اتمنى ما اكونش يعني ثم طبعا على المستوى
بقى التفاصيل يعني الراعي الرئيسي او
الدعم الرئيسي لحركه الجهاد هي ايران
الداعم الرئيسي لحماس لا دول اخرى منها
ايران هتلاقي بقى عندك ايران هتلاقي عندك
تركيا هتلاقي عندك قطر
دول اخرى
كيف يمكن لخريج الهندسه اجابنا اخونا
اسمايلي لماذا التاريخ 2030 يعتبر بدايه
للنظام العالمي الجديد غير سليم يا اخونا
اخونا نعمان انا قالت نعمان لاني مش عارف
على الاسم الاولاني يا نعمان اكون شاكر لو
كتبته اساميكم لو لم تكونوا احب ان
اخاطبكم باسمائكم هو ناس بتوع تقدر كده
يعني ما فيش سر في 2030 ولكن يقول لك مثلا
انت قدرتنا انه
الميزان التجاري او الميزان الاقتصادي
هيكون حسني لصالح الاقتصاد خلال عده سنوات
فعلشان هو مش حاسبها بالالم والورقه بيديك
تاريخ كده يعني
2030 الف ممكن يبقى 2029 ممكن
لا يوجد سر يتعلق بالفين وثلاثين التواريخ
عاده بتبقى تقريبيه واحيانا رمزيه يعني
يقول لك مثلا انه الصين
نقطه الانطلاق والتغيير والسيطره على مثلا
تايوان هتكون قبل 20249
ليه يا ابو رامي اللي بيحب التاريخ 20249
لان هي انشاء الدوله الصينيه الحديثه ديت
جمهوريه الصين الشعبيه كان 1949 فعاوز
يقول ان انا خلال مئه عام منذ الانشاء
عملت كذا اردوغان مثلا وضع
يعني استخدم اتفاقيه لوزان 23 بشكل رمزي
في حملاته السابقه عشان يقول ان 23 ديت
كلها مغزى كبير جدا ده بعد 23 هنكون انتهت
كل الفتره فتره كمال اتاتورك وما سبقها
وكذا وهتكون مئويه اخرى تبدا بعد 23 يعني
دايما حاجات رمزيه بيستغلها السياسيين او
كذا يعني
واحنا عندنا اسئله كتير
راي حضرتك في تسليح الدولار ومدى تاثيره
على مخ على على امريكا في ظل النمو الصين
وروسيا عسكريه من اقتصاديا عسكرت الدولار
هو اللي انا اتكلمت عليه يا علي خطاب في
اول القصه انه اولا هي امريكا بتعملوا ليه
امريكا تقدر تقول عليها باختصار ينطبق
عليها المثل الامريكي اللي بيقول اذا كانت
كل الادوات التي لديك هي فقط الحمر او
الشاكوش فانت ترى كل المشاكل المسامير
يعني اذا كان كل ما لديك هو
الحمر او
مرزق والشاكوش ده فانت لما بتشوفش المشاكل
الاخرى غير عباره عن مسامير لان انت عندك
اداء واحده هتعمل ايه عاوز تستخدمها في كل
مره هو لا يوجد الا القوه
في ايده لانه هو عاوز يحافظ على صدرته في
قياده العالم وتراجعت قدراته فكل اللي في
ايده عباره عن وسائل القهر في استخدام
الدولار في استخدام القوه العسكريه وهكذا
ردا على سؤالك ايه تاثير ان انا اسلح
الدولار بان انا استخدم هيمنه الدولار
لعقاب الدول الاخرى اللي بتضع اموالها
عندي في سندات نتيجه هيمنه الدولار
فاجمدها واعاقب الناس ولان السويفت عندي
ولانه نظام الساتل ما انت عندي التسويه من
العملات عندي النتيجه ان الدول كثيره بدات
وده احد الاسباب اللي ادى الى انتعاش
عمليه البحث عن بدائل للدولار
السيد ما شاء الله عليك على طريق على
طريقتك في السرد رائعه اتمنى تقول لنا ايه
رايك في اللي بيحصل في السودان وهل سيستمر
من وجهه نظرك رجب والله يا اخونا رجب
اشكرك كثر خيرك على المجامله الطيبه
انا عندي قناعه في
فيما يتعلق في النظر للامور يعني هم
بيقسموها ايه مدارس في العلاقات الدوليه
يقول لك دائريه ليبرالي وده انا
بميل ان انا اكون
وكلمه تبدو ترجمتها الحرفيه واقعي بس افتح
قوسين عاده لاكونوا متفائلا كثيرا
عاوز تعرف المدرسه الواقعيه في حلقه
اتكلمت فيها عن المدرسه الواقعيه والمدرسه
الليبراليه بس الحقيقه لا اذكر اسمها الان
ولكن اظن ان الصام نيل القانون الذي يحكم
العالم
[موسيقى]
فممكن تصل اليها يعني وهتجدها اصلا في
حلقه بعنوان اللي بتتكلم عن الليبراليه
لماذا تعتبر امريكا نفسها خير امه اخرجت
للناس اذا وصلت للحلقه ديت هتوصل للحلقه
التانيه اللي بكلمك عليها كل المقدمه دي
عشان اقول لك ايه عشان اقول لك انه بالنظر
الى ما يحدث في السودان
وبالنظر الى قناعتي كاريه يعني فانا لا
اتوقع حلا سريعا للازمه في السودان
للاسباب التاليه واحد انه الاطراف
الخارجيه غير قادره على السيطره على
الاطراف المحليه اتنين الاطراف المحليه
اتبعت الباترن اللي بيحصل في كل الصراعات
المشابهه ومنه صراعات سابقه في السودان
يبدا الصراع ان كل طرف معتقد انه سوف
يحسمه في ايام فبيبدا عنيف جدا ثم يدرك
بعد مرور اسبوع اثنين ثلاثه اربعه خمسه
انه غير قادر فبيبتدي يبحث عن اطراف محليه
جديده
واطراف وشركاء وداعمين من الخارج
وبالتالي يتسع امد الصراع ويزداد الصراع
اتساعا انه اثناء الحرب لازم يتم جر اطراف
ما كانت راغبه انك تهاجم على قبيله من عرق
معين من دين معين وبتجد انه الحرب بتدخل
فيها اطراف وتتسع اغراضها كان الغرض سيطره
الجيش على
الدعم السريع او ان الدعم السريع يسيطر
على الجيش او يحظى بامتيازات اكبر تلاقي
اطراف بتحارب اطراف اخرى لاسباب مذهبيه
اسباب عرقيه
طرف اخر بقت انه تضرر ان الحكومه المركزيه
لا تليه اي اهتمام فيفكر في انفصل
بالمنطقه اللي فيها وبالتالي للاسف
السودان
اذا حسم هذه الصراع فسوف ياخذ وقتا طويلا
اتمنى نربينا يخيب ظني ولكن ليس هناك ما
يدعو للتفاؤل
سؤال استاذ سيد برايك من المستفيد قلنا
على مساله خرسون احمد عطيه الياس متى
تتجرا اجابنا حمزه هل سينهي عوده العلاقات
بين السعوديه وايران مشروع ايران السفر في
التمدد ونشر التشيع انا ما اعرفش ان في
مشروع لنشر التشيع والله ما اعرف وبقول ما
اعرفش بمعنى ان انا ما اعرفش فعلا وبستنكر
هذا يا ران ما كانش هدفها التشيعه ما في
شك انها استخدمت
بعض الناس بعض الناس وليس كل ناس ليس كل
شيء عراقي ايراني الهوى وليس كل شيعي
بحريني او سعودي ايراني الهوى ولكنها ما
في شك انها استغلت
التشيع او الشيعه او قوه شيعيه في كل بلد
لصالحها هذا صحيح ولكن ان هي تسعى يعني
لتشييع السنه لا اعتقد ان هذا كان من
اولويات ايران اصلا يعني
ومع ذلك نقول مشروع ايران انا معرفش ايه
قصدك بالصفو لان دائما التعبيرات اللي
بنستخدموها علشان
يعني يسيئوا الى ايران لكن اقدر اقول لك
انها لن تتوقف ابدا عن عن السيطره على
ادوات النفوذ لها اللي تؤمن مصالحها بها
بكل السبل لا هي هتتوقف ولا اي دوله اخرى
تتوقف وتبقى غافله لو توقفت لانها ان وضعت
سلاحها النهارده يعني الادوات اللي بتحفظ
بها مصالحها هيتم اسقاطها في اليوم التالي
الكلام ده ينطبق على ايران وينطبق على
امريكا وينطبق على الهند وينطبق على
الدول العربيه وهكذا ما فيش حد بيسيب كارت
في ايده للدفاع عن مصالحه
بس انت مثلا واخد موقف منها فبتصورها
كانها دوله معتديه وما بتقولش على الدوله
اللي انت فيها هي بتعمل ايه في الداخل
الايراني انا ما اعرفش طبعا دولتك ولكن
اكيد لو هي المشتركه مع ايران فهي تسعى
بكل السبل واذا لم تكن قد سعت لانها غير
قادره لاي سبب
ما هو وضع ليبيا الحالي وضع سيء جدا جدا
جدا جدا جدا جدا جدا ووضع سريالي بين ناس
يعني لا عندهم رغبه ولا قدره على انهم
يتصالحوا القدره يعني نقدر نقعد نتكلم مع
بعض والرغبه انه حتى لو مش قادرين يبقى
نتمنى يعني هم لا قدره ولا رغبه لان هم
مستفيدين من الصراع الموجود يعني الناس
بيجي النفط يبيعوه ويوزعه على بعض بما
فيهم الميليشيات فالامور جميله جدا يعني
ما فيش اي شيء خالص
ما هو رايك حول صاروخ فتاح لاعلم عنه شيئا
ده صاروخ يعني
كيف يمكن لخريج الهندسه اجابنا جابنا
محمد بشير شكرا على مجهوداتك الجباره
وربنا يقدرك تستمر ويجازيك كل خير الله
يخليك يا محمد والله شاكر جدا محمد عطوان
تحياتي استاذ سيد حدثنا عن الازمه
الاقتصاديه الثانيه ده كان موضوع الحلقه
والله يا محمد هو ده
طيب انا هقول لك على حاجه انا كنت عاوز
اقول كلام كتير
وان شاء الله هدي لك فكره صغيره يعني لكن
انا هعمل حاجتين الحاجه الاولانيه ان شاء
الله ان شاء الله ما يكون في حلقه نتوقعت
عملت سيناريوهين ان الناس تهتم لان ال54%
في الاستفتاء قالوا لي عاوزين الموضوع ده
بس برضو تحوطا ان بتيجي احداث من ساعه ما
بعد لغايه ما اجي احيانا المباشر بينجرف
فانا
سجلت حلقه تحوطا مع صديقي هاني جنينه على
نعرف اقتصاد سوف تذا غدا ان شاء الله مساء
عن الازمه الاقتصاديه الصينيه
ده واحد
التفاصيل
اقتصاد كاقتصاد فقط وكثير من الاقتصاد
وقليل من السياسه وهناك فرق كبير غدا في
حلقه على نعرف اقتصاد مع صديقي الاقتصاد
المحترم
الامر الثاني ان شاء الله على نعرف الام
هتكلم على الازمه الاقتصاديه الصينيه مره
اخرى ولكن هيكون كثير من السياسه وقليل من
الاقتصاد خلال اسبوع مقبل باذن الله لكن
باختصار احتراما لهذا السؤال وطبعا ده كان
موضوع الحلقه انه الصين عندها مؤشرات
مقلقه اقتصاديا وتقدر تلخص مشاكل الصين
الثلاثه الكبيره المشكله الاولانيه هو
تراجع في معدل السكان لاول مره يعني
تقريبا منذ نشات
الجمهوريه الصينيه الشيوعيات سنه 49 يعني
بدل ما كان السكان بيزيدوا كل سنه عن
العام الاخر معدل الزياده بينخفض بحيث انه
هيقل العدد في السنه المقبله عناء السنه
الماضيه ده واحد انا عارف ان ده لحد ذاته
يطرح اسئله اخرى وهو تراجع معدل السكان
كويس ولا وحش هقول لحضرتك حالا لكن رقم
واحد ان هي فقدت وضعاك اكثر دوله من حيث
عدد السكان ده رقم واحد رقم اثنين انه
عندها زياده
رهيبه في الديون
اختصارا كده بلغت حوالي 300 في الميه من
الناتج المحلي الاجمالي للصيني يعني
الناتج المحلي الاجمالي في
كان حوالي 18 تريليون هي ديونها تقريبا
ثلاث اضعاف هذا الرقم يعني مش مهم بالدقه
قوي لانه 295 في الميه في 2022 هتبقى 300
في الميه من رقم 18 هيبقى 20 وال295
هيكونوا 300% هذا العام فالفرق للتسهيل
يعني لا التسهيل لو قلت انه الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي لها عشرين تريليون دولار الناتج
الديونها حوالي 60 تريليون ولمن يرغب في
التدقيق 18 تريليون 2022
والديون له على الدوله وعلى الشركات وعلى
الافراد 295 في المئه نسبه ديونك هائله
جدا
المشكله الثالثه واللي هي فيها قدر كبير
من السياسه انه نتيجه الصراع ما بين القوى
الكبرى الولايات المتحده وحلفائها بداوا
يفرضوا عليها ح روب تجاريه خلاصتها كالاتي
انه يحرموها من التكنولوجيا المتقدمه ما
استطاعوا الى ذلك سبيلا اثنين انه يحرموها
من دخول اسواقهم ما استطاعوا الى ذلك
سبيلا تلاته ان يخرجوا باستثماراتهم من
الصين الى الدول الام اللي هي امريكا
اوروبا او لدول بديله زي مثلا الهند او
غيرها
ما استطاعوا الى ذلك سبيلا يبقى عندنا دول
المشاكل التلاته الصرع مع الغرب بيتفاقم
ما يضرها لانها كانت اكثر الدول العالم
استهداف استفاده من العولمه اتنين
زياده الديون اللي هي غزه النمو في
الفترات السابقه ثلاثه اللي هو تراجع معدل
السكان هدي تعليق صغير على معدل السكان
ولانه في حد يقول لي طب ما هو مثلا في دول
بيقول لها انت مشكلتك ان عدد السكان كتير
عدد السكان ممكن يبقى
مفيد عدد السكان ممكن يبقى مضر يتوقف على
التركيب السكانيه ما انت لو عندك عدد
السكان بيزيد في الشرائح
الفقيره اللي هي بتلقى قدر القليل جدا من
التعليم وما بتتعلمش مهارات فيها مشكله
اذا كان عندك السكان عدد كبير والتعليم
جيد والقدره على تدريبه وتوظيفه بشكل كويس
ده ايجابي هل انما هي تبقى مليار و400
مليون السنه اللي فاتت والسنه دي تبقى او
بعد خمس سنين لا يزيد العدد ويزيد عدد
الهند اللي هي اصبحت اكثر دول العالم
ازديدا معناها كده انه هي في مصيبه لا ما
فيش مصيبه حاجه ولكن اللي بيقولوا ان ده
مؤشر سلبي اولا في تفاصيل تتعلق بالتركيب
السكانيه الصينيه
انه هيجدوا ان الشباب هيتراجع هتبقى في
نسبه كتيره من العجائز هيبقى زيها زي
اليابان معناه ان النمو اللي بتعتمد عليه
داخليا ان السوق الصيني مكتفي بنفسه حتى
لو لم يصدر يقدر يعتمد على السوق المحلي
هيتراجع ثم ان الكلام ده على المستوى
البعيد سنه خمس سنين عشر سنين 20 سنه ناقد
تواجه مشكله واجهتها دول تراجع معدل نمو
السكاني زي اوروبا الغربيه وزي اليابان
وهناك مشكله كبيره تتعلق بالقطاع العقاري
للعقار لانه انعكاس للي انا قلته ده اذا
كان انت عندك تراجع في معدل نمو السكان
واذا كان عندك ديون كتيره واذا كان عندك
خروج للاستثمارات لازم هيكون معدل النمو
هيتراجع وفعلا تراجع معدل النمو لواحد من
اقل مستوياته في تاريخ دوله الصين اللي هو
3% يعني على الاقل الدقه من سنه سته
وسبعين يعني منذ
عمليه الاصلاح الاقتصادي مش من سنه 49
تراجع النمو معناه تراجع الانتاج معناه
تراجع الطلب معناها تراجعت التوظيف طيب
لما يحصل كل ده وانا عندي وفره في المعروض
من العقارات يبقى يبقى مش هيكون في مبيعات
ما فيش مبيعات يعني هذا القطاع اللي
بيتجاوز
[موسيقى]
بالانشطه الكثيره المرتبطه ب 25% من
الناتج المحلي الاجمالي للصين معناها انه
هيبتدي شركات تتعثر وفي شركات بتتعثر فعلا
لان مش قادره تستكمل المشروعات اللي
بداتها معناها ان اموال الناس اللي وضعت
في هذه العقارات قد تبخرت وهكذا الصين
عندها مؤشرات تقول انها قد يعني تواجه
ازمه كبيره تؤثر عليها لسنوات وتبقى شبيهه
بازمه 2008 في امريكا وفي وجهه نظر بتقول
كل المتاعب دي موجوده ولكن البتاع دي ليست
حديثه تمكنت الصين من
[موسيقى]
معالجتها ويمكن ان تعالجها ولا تنفجر هذا
العام او العام المقبل
لو حصلت حرب بين امريكا والصين من يخرج
منتصرا
ما فيش حد هيخرج منتصرا يا صديقي العالم
سوف يخرب كيف يمكن اجبني لو حصلت اجابنا
متى تتجرا اجابنا كيف استطاع الحكم
الديكتاتوري في الصين ان يكون امبراطوريه
عظمى هل يمكن لدولنا العربيه ان تسير على
خطط تجربه الصينيه خصوصا
ان الديمقراطيه لم تنجح في دولنا العربيه
شكرا واتمنى ان ارى مثلك في الاعلام ربنا
يخليك يا ابراهيم انا في الاعلام انا
الصحفي يا ابراهيم من مش طبيب اسنان يعني
تقصد في التلفزيون لا انا مش حابب تجربه
التلفزيون ربنا يخليك لكن عاوز اقول لك
على حاجه يا ابراهيم السؤال ده سؤال كبير
وصعب جدا صعب جدا بمعنى ايه انه انت علشان
تقول
تصف الحكم في الصين بانه ديكتاتور هذا
توصيف الغرب للحكم الصيني هل معنى ذلك ان
هو ديمقراطي لا هو مش ديمقراطي بس هو نظام
حكم يختلف عن الحكم الغربي
يعني بمعنى ايه انه هذا نظام تشكل في دوله
الصين العظمى على مدار الاف السنين في
ثقافه مختلفه طب ما اشوف ثقافه اليابان
مثلا انت عندك هو ان الزوجه مثلا
بتتعامل مع زوجها رغم ان هم اخذوا كثير من
القيم الغربيه بس عندهم طاعه الزوجه للزوج
قاعه الاخ الصغير الاخ الكبير انا قرات
ولم اتبين يعني ادقق فيها ودائما بنسى انا
ادقق فيها انه احد اسباب عدم انتشار نظام
العبوديه في بعض الدول الاسيويه واليابان
ولم تكن هناك حاجه لنظام العبوديه لان
الاخ الكبير او الاب او الزوج بيحضى بطاعه
تلقائيه من عشيرته يعني ثقافه
وبالتالي كلمه نظام ديكتاتوري قد لا تكون
كلمه دقيقه محتاجه تدقيق في الكلمه بعيدا
عن الوصف الغربي اللي بيصف اي حاجه مختلفه
عنه بانها سيئه اتنين انه كل انه في حكم
مركزي قوي لحزب الحزب ده في حوالي 100
مليون فمش حزب صغير
وفيس كتير وبالتالي اداره متسعه والواضح
جدا ان هم ناجحوا حتى هذه اللحظه في ان
هذا النظام يكون مرن لانه انت عندك نظام
صناعي ناجح عندك مستثمرين سعداء عندك
سياحه شغاله عندك تعليم ناجح عندك ابحاث
علميه تفوقت على الولايات المتحده والغرب
من 2020 عندك جيش مزدهر عندك
لترتشر او ادب وعندك صحافه وعندك كتابات
فمش ممكن يكون الوضع زي ما احنا متخيلين
ان هناك حاكم واحد يعني
[موسيقى]
متحكم في الامور زي ما انت متخيل الامر في
بعض دول الشرق الاوسط هي تجربه مختلفه
وكبيره جدا يصعب القياس عليها مش عارف اذا
كنت اجبت عليك ولا لخبطتك يعني
انا هستاذنكم ان انا اكتفي كمان بخمس
دقائق
ونستكمل ان شاء الله الاسبوع اللي جاي
مرحبا مره اخرى استاذ سيد علي عبود نحن في
سوريا نعرف اسرائيل بانها كيان توسعي توق
لمزيد من الاعراض على حساب دول الجوار هل
مازال هذا التصور واقعي في 2023 ده في
رايي انا سوف يظل الى الابد
لا لا يمكن ابدا ان اسلم بوجهه النظر اللي
بعض
يعني الراغبين في اعطاء صوره
يعني
متعاطفين مع اسرائيل ولا اعرف سبب التعاطف
ما اعرفه انه اوكي تعيش في الحدود اللي
قالتها الامم المتحده وخلاص اصبح امرا
واقعا لكن هي لم تقبل بهذا الامر الواقع
هي عاوزه اراضي
الفلسطينيين وعاوزه تاخد الجولان وعاوزه
تاخد
لو تمكنت من المملكه الهاشميه وعاوزه تقيد
حركه الدول العربيه كلها الا يكون لديها
تفوق باي شكل يمكن ان يهددها ولن ترتاح
طالما انه ايران اللي هي تبعد عنها يعني
الا اذا تاكدت انها اضعف بكثير مما هي
عليه
عمرو بيقول
راويه
ارسلت
سؤال قررته الف مره اللي هو مواضع اليمن
حاليا
انا مش قدام السؤال بس هو شايف انه
انه يعني
تكرر كثيرا يا استاذه راويه اليمن
بعد عمليه التصالح الايراني
السعودي كانت هناك بارقه امل وفعلا بارقه
الامل ديت
انعكست على تهدئه عامه نسبيا مهياش مطلقه
من خلال التبادل السجناء من خلال وضع حل
لمشكله صافر اللي هي كانت بتؤرق يعني دول
المنطقه من خلال الجلوس على مائله
المفاوضات وزياره وفود عربيه ومنها وفد
سعودي وهناك مفاوضات لكن كل جهود التهدئه
ديت اولا لسه في مراحلها الاولى فمن
المبكر ان نحكم عليها ولكن هناك بارقه امل
انه يمكن للاطراف المختلفه ان تجلس على
بقيت مفرد هذا هو الايجابي
اللي هيحتاج الى وقت طويل انه
[موسيقى]
موازين القوى اللي
تشكلت على الارض بعد على مدار السنوات
الطويله الماضيه ديت بتقول انه لا يمكن
تقرص اوت الحوت الان ما تقدرش ان انت
تستبعده وبالتالي
السعوديه لما تقعد مع الحوثه هيكون هدفها
الاساسي ان هي تامن على نفسها من هجماته
لما الاماراتيين من خلف الجدران
والعمانيين والقطريين عاوزين يحموا
مصالحهم لما المجلس الانتقالي والناس
الجنوبيين عاوزين يحافظوا على على انفصال
الجنوب
فالجهود الخارجيه هتسعى للتهدئه فتح مضيق
باب المندب عدم التاكد من ضمانات انه
العدوان اللي جوه او الفعاليات اللي جوه
لا تنزاح على دول الجوار ان دول الجوار
تتوقف عن العدوان والضرب يخف
الاحتقان اللي موجود وممكن تبقى في
مساعدات لكن الحاجه اللي هتحتاج وقت كثير
جدا هو حل بقى الخريطه اللي جوه ديت من
سوف يتفاوض مع من على ماذا يعني هل
الجنوبيين او القوه الجنوبيين وهم ليسوا
على قلب رجل واحد هيقبلوا ببقاء الوضع
الموجود عليه هل الحوث هيكتفي بما لديه
فدي قصه
من المبكر جدا معرفتها
كيف يمكن اجابنا بما ان البث بيتكلم عن
الاقتصاد مصر تملك ثروه سكانيه وعلميه
كبيره مثل تركيا ايضا ما هي العقبات التي
يواجهها اقتصاد صحيح ان الجيش يعرق
للتنميه في مصر المرسل احمد الحربي لا
المشكله اكبر بكتيريا احمد اولا في
التوصيف انت بتقول انه مصر بتملك ثروه
سكانيه تملك عدد سكان كبير لازم نقول
توصيف عدد السكري الكبير اذا كانت نسبه
الاميه وفقا للارقام الرسميه تتجاوز 17
وتصل الى 20% ده الاميه الرسميه يبقى انت
عندك مشكله ما بين كل ميه بالارقام
الرسميه من 17 الى 20 لا يوجد القراءه
والكتابه اذا عرفت الاميه بشكل سليم وقلت
اللي بيعرف قراءه والكتابه وعنده مهارات
تمكنه من العمل هتلاقي النسبه اكبر بكثير
جدا جدا انت بتقول الكثير من العلماء صحيح
احنا مليون مصر مليون
وخمسه يعني مليون
مليون يعني ولكن عدد العلماء الحقيقيين
والمؤثرين في كل ما كان عددهم محتاجه
مراجعه قدرتهم على التحرك في ظل
البيروقراطيه اللي موجوده محتاجه مراجعه
الاهم من كل ده انت عندك كفاءات في
الاقتصاد وفي السياسه بقطع النظر عن العدد
ما هي نفس القصه في السودان ما عندهم
اطباء وعندهم علماء وعندهم انما المناخ
كله حتى الان لم ينجح السودانيون في ان
يوقفوا هذه الكفاءات ومصر حتى هذه اللحظه
لم تضع يدها على مفتاح النهضه ازاي انا
اعمل نظام يسمح لكل هذه الطاقات بان هي
يتم استغلالها اديك مثال اتنين تلاته
اربعه خمسه ممكن اكلم حضرتك ثلاث ايام
احنا عندنا مشاريع مثلا عقاريه ضخمه جدا
من القطاع الخاص ومن الدوله ولكن ما حدش
بيقول لنا مثلا كيف يتم استغلال الوحدات
السكانيه اللي هي مغلقه موجوده دي حلها
تشريع ولكن التشريع ده ما بيتاخدش ليه
تكتشف انه صراع بين قوه مجتمعيه كبيره مش
مرتبطه يعني مش لازم يبقى هو السيسي عامل
ده السيسي ده رئيس دوله بياخد قرارات
بعضها مصيب وبعضها خاطئ انا بتكلم على
الدوله المصريه كلها على بعضها الان
وقبلها تجد ان في صراع ما بين الملاك
والمستاجرين وشركات العقارات قصه بين لك
انه في صراعه دور الدوله بقى ان هي تحدد
اولوياتها اولويتي ان انا احقق عائد من
مشروعات جديده ولا
وفر هذا العائد وانا استغل العقارات اللي
موجوده واستغل الفلوس اللي هي بتذهب الى
العقارات واستغلها في تنميه كثيره
انت عندك
علماء عندك
عندك عندك كفاءات في كل مكان طب انا محتاج
تشريعات تسمح لي ان انا
الطاقات دي ممكن تنطلق محتاج ان انا اعدل
التشريعات تعديل التشريعات بيصطدم بمصالح
كثيره وهكذا فالاجابه المختصره لحضرتك انه
دول كثيره لديها علماء دول كثيره لديها
كفاءات ولكن يجب ان يكون المناخ كله على
بعض يسمح لهذه الكفاءات ان هي تعمل ولما
السيستم ده هيشتغل اللي هو هيكون عباره عن
تشريعات واضحه هيكون عباره عن سياده قانون
وسياده القانون دي مش هنبقى في الجنه يعني
عند ربنا ولكن بقدر معقول في دول انت
اتكلمت على تركيا انا لا انسى ابدا ان كان
عندي ضيف عراقي جذرني مشكورا وفي وسط
الكلام اهم كلمه هو اتكلم كثير وقال
معلومات جميله لكن قال لي انا بقول لي ان
انا قاعد في تركيا ف ليه تركيا قال لي
اصله هو ما كنش بنتكلم سياسه ده احنا
قاعدين بنشرب قهوه فقال لي اصل انا مرتاح
هناك انت بتاخد حقك طالما انت ما عندكش
مشاكل سياسيه ولا كذا والقانون بيسود اكيد
تركيا ما هياش الجنه واكيد في تجاوزات بس
هو بيتكلم كمواطن او مقيم فخلاص قانون
بيتطبق فده كان احد ازدهار تركيا رغبه
الانتهاكات الموجوده رغم الديمقراطيه
المعيبه لكن وضعها افضل من دول اخرى كثيرا
وعليه فانه الوضع في اي دوله علشان يزدهر
لما يكون متاذيب يبقى في خلل امتى تعرف ان
الدوله ديت تجاوزت مشاكلها وبقى عندها
نهضه لما تبتدي القوانين يتم تستفها
وترتيبها بحيث انه التعليم يمشي في مساره
وانت بتقضي مصالحك من غير كل هذا الجهد
والاقتصاديين شغالين والعلماء شغالين وكل
الطاقات بشكل جماعي
قول
بيقول عاوز حلقه عن الاقتصاد السوري على
نعرف
هي بس عاطف
اه او ما دول الكوارث سؤال كتير ومش عارف
اوصل لهم مش كده
السؤال مروان الاقتصاد السوري احنا
اتكلمنا عليه انا مشكلتي بس في الاقتصاد
السوري انه عشان الارقام تقولها بشكل دقيق
لازم تكون متوفره والدول اللي في حاله حرب
زي سوريا وزي اليمن ما تقدرش تتكلم بشكل
علمي قوي عليه لان كثير من الارقام بتبقى
مش متوفره البلد عندها حاله طوارئ لكن
بنتكلم بصفه عامه كده لكن يعني انا مش
بوعدك ان تكون حلقه لان ده يكون مرتبط
بتوفر الارقام بشكل دقيق
انا اسف ان انا هتوقف انا عارف ان في عدد
كبير جدا ولا ما فيش عدد كبير من الاسئله
معلش سامحوني يعني انا كنت ارغب النهارده
يعني الحقيقه في التوقف عند العاشره بس
استاذنكم في حاجتين بعد الاعتذار على انني
لم اتمكن من اجابه الاسئله
وبعتذر ان انا مش هقدر اكمل على الاقل
الساعه 11 اكتفي بالقدر دوت لاسباب لطول
شرحها يعني ان شاء الله كل اللي كان له
سؤال ولم نجب عليه ان شاء الله الاربعاء
القادم في نفس الموعد باذن الله استاذنكم
دون ان ينزعج والله ما شفت ولا سؤال
واتجاهلته يعني وانتم يمكن تكونوا ملاحظين
لكن الاسئله الاخرى ان شاء الله نجيب عنها
في الاسبوع المقبل ولا تنسوا متابعه حلقه
وكان الحلقه الاخيره اللي هي كانت اللي
بيسالوني عن ايران ومصر في حلقه انا
عملتها امبارح على نعرف الام اذا كنت
مهتمين بالمساله تابعوها
والاقتصاد الصيني حلقه ان شاء الله بكره
على نعرف اقتصاد والاسبوع المقبل حلقه عن
العلاقات الصينيه الامريكيه اشكركم والى
لقاء